hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to
border officer if you're thinking to
yourself that this seems a lot like
papers please i have no idea if you're
correct or not this is
border officer very different legally
distinct probably from papers please
and it involves you being a officer at
the border
very different you have to inspect
people's
documentation and see them through the
border
very different i got this because it
looked like one of those games that was
going to be absolutely
garbage but the reviews were halfway
decent
so i'm kind of curious as to why i don't
know
maybe i'm going into this prejudice
maybe i shouldn't be so judgmental
i have legs harlow
i have a happiness bar which is
depressing because that means it can go
down
i need to open the door hi wife
what what wife wife his wife
what am i looking at what border
crossing open from now on
stavroska can be accessed from the
outside very different
a wife why if your happiness looks a
little low
your happiness is only 64 you cigarette
addict can you give me some cigarettes
on the way home honey i'll give you a
cigarette
did i have one let's meet in the night
what i feel so good we had good food i'm
full i feel warm
let's meet in the night don't forget to
be energetic in bed
all right hey wife listen uh i'll see
you
later hang on i gotta get to the door
a little bear never hurt nobody before a
shift
oh grandma mother-in-law hello if you
give me money i will fix your
relationship with someone no i will
break your relationship if you don't
the hell lady feels so good you're not
gonna feel good in a little bit all
right
money i decided to correct your
relationship with your uncle
thanks i guess oh is that my uncle
it's my uncle hello give me something to
drink looks like my head's
coming
oh kid son sorry son yeah i recognized
you son
i'd know that face anywhere could you
give me some chocolate the taste was
very nice
he likes chocolate what a quirk okay
person you to sell the product may
affect the morale of the family well i'm
not going to do
that oh
hi um i'll be right there yeah
hi hello
okay contract you know we've decided to
open the border gate and here
we offer people new jobs the raffle in
march was announced your name came out
of the list congratulations you have a
job now
we apologize for sending the letter late
we sent you a special car
you already know the house you've
already moved
what and there's also a bus service what
sign the contract is this the contract
this is it there's a lot of legality
here that is missing from this contract
a lot of their fours in their end and in
such a case that is that
is thus not enough buses or i'll sign it
whatever i'm waiting in the car
do not be late i don't even know what
time it is do you have a clock
we're too poor to have a clock it's just
like my childhood all over again
why would wood wood
i gotta worry about wood chop
chop i just picked up an axe
do not sass me put it in my hand
chop i did it
rotten and useless well that was
pointless then all right dude oh i'm
driving you shouldn't
you shouldn't have you sweetheart do i
have to drive there go straight man this
road will lead us to the border oh my
god
this is made by the same people that
made livestream simulator
oh my god it's the same the man before
you got
fired for taking a bribe be careful with
inspectors coming to the border
don't forget to pay your rent the state
is very serious about it but that's good
because that means this is going to be
pretty well made
i mean well not not well made but like
enough made it's gonna be made as
opposed to a lot of things
which
are fine we're fine we're all good
deer that's a wolf
ah that's the highway man
gasoline food even gambling wait this is
i thought it was just gonna be about the
border officer if you hunt you can
find a wolf try to tame try to tame a
wolf this is a lot of information just
put on me right now you can go to work
by
bus but the money means everything in
straw stavronska you will learn to save
money huh huh strip club
hmm hey how about a pit stop is your
favorite place
all right let's go check it out i'm
coming back here after i'm done with you
come on go ahead
go ahead and into the building with an
axe you can earn money by selling
livestock or wood
hey bud all right i'll pay the fee
well beer don't mind if i do take one or
two two is just
oh hey man either i'm
smashed out of my gourd or this is the
greatest party i've ever seen in my life
this ain't no strip club this is a
heaven this is a dance
oh it's a place where you dance
this guy yeah no one mined my axe
excuse me sorry pardon me what is with
your head wait wait
whoa whoa
i swear this isn't just a look at her
boobs
something went wrong with the morph
all right sorry back to serious business
man my family's not gonna be happy about
that i gotta make sure i have enough
energy when i get back from my wife you
know
this is so bizarre i thought it was just
going to be a show up at the border
and there you go kind of thing but
apparently
it's so much more it's like a dream come
true
which is odd because the live stream
simulator
really consumed my existence and i would
hate it if this one's
game loop is just satisfying enough that
it actually made me
really interested in the game that would
be something else i don't know why i'm
automatically assuming that's a bad
thing but something about it feels like
it's a bad thing maybe i should hit a
deer
and then put it in my trunk i could feed
my family excuse me
dear dear locked on target baby get
ready to get screwed
that is a tough deer all right how about
with an axe well
axe gotta do it right hey [ __ ] no no no
no no i'm gonna whump you in your butt
really really this is doing nothing for
you this is not doing a thing all right
fine
i'm wasting all my energy that i'm going
to give to my wife i hope time was kind
of paused while we were doing this
because this
is going to be a problem and a quarter
of a tank of gas just to get there i'm
taking the bus from now on also if this
is the border where
where are people you know usually
borders people
kind of come and go is this a parking
spot i don't know
bye okay bye are you gonna explain this
weird job oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
that's fine hello hello
hello start working yeah sure
uh military hat sure danger open it you
need permission a rest you need a key
turn on operating system scanner
approval stamp rejection stamp okay this
is way different than i thought it'd be
oh but
it's gonna be like yeah all right speech
speech history announcements
announcement number one
anyone who wants to cross a border needs
an entry permit due to fraud and
passports
okay example entry permit
okay diplomats need a diplomat entry
permit and a passport they are not
affected by general rules
okay tutorials okay look at this i
i i know the general gist of it sniper
i get to shoot people you know let's
just go for it uh
this clearly ain't gonna be good on my
first try but
the thief stole your my uncle's bed
what next come on in
uh my my uncle's bed was just stolen i
could have sworn he was on it
what's wrong with your tired of these
controls that's the purpose of your
visit
uh entry permit wait a minute
wait wait a minute well this ain't you
this ain't you at all no i deny you
bam you get denied [ __ ]
take him get out of here
uh hang on i'm new to this um because
sworn that
maybe that would be it and you'd go but
can you leave me alone can i detect you
um really don't know what the hell i'm
doing
can you go what do i do
what do i do leave me alone i'm
so unbelievably lost i'm gonna shoot him
i'm shooting him
rest this man
oh [ __ ] oh details about the citizen a
man is dead not guilty
in juicier is a little faster we don't
have the money to put people in prison
oh ah oops
next who's next all right hey how you
doing
don't worry about a thing everything's
gonna be fine
hello good work thank you purposes of
your visit
are you guys soulless in any good blazes
inside
uh i have a wife thank you very much
okay
names max of work date of birth always
be in order let's see if it works let's
let's see what happens hey let's roll
the dice here
oh give oh you just click and get oh
you don't die today what you made one
mistake the penalty will be applied at
what there was a c form
she had a bomb she had a [ __ ] bomb
huh do you got a bomb you get scanned
first [ __ ]
okay oh [ __ ]
i thought i heard him didn't didn't it
beep what's happening
oh it's cuz his computer okay never mind
it's a little gift
what what's a gift to me what's the gift
you dare
you dare bribe me looks like you didn't
need to because everything's in order
so didn't really have to everything
seems to match up
am i crazier is this just a nice gift
thanks for the gift man
hey there was someone with a bomb the
other day so i mean
two minutes ago you know glad you are
understanding thank you
oops sorry meant to do this
there you go and i'll take one of these
thanks bud
next you're gonna get scanned hey you
got
bombs on you really worried about bombs
today for some reason
came for the doctor okay i'm sure we
have good doctors here this
ain't you at all what's wrong with you
get get out get just get
go before i have you shot which
apparently i can do
get out of here get out of here
yeah well your picture didn't match
you're not the lady with a bomb you're
lucky i didn't shoot you
next all right get in here faster come
on chippity chop
hip
[Music]
this is my country this here okay
well this okay this well that's just
this is not right you see how you see
how this is kind of
terrible you see you do you see how this
is i could shoot you and no one would
say a word
it cost me five bucks and i just got
five bucks letting you off with a little
warning
then the warning says get out you hate
me
well i hate you we all hate you and but
you know what loves you a bullet a
bullet would love you
i swear to god if you blow me up
i will blow you away wait a minute
something's going on here
a fork why do you have a fork side of
the alarm
he's got a fork arrested
wait is a fork okay or something oh a
fork's okay isn't oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
anyway maybe i was supposed to die oh
god he was so nice oh
god no wait hang on oh [ __ ]
yeah yep yeah that's my bad
yes my bad boss yeah boss that's my bad
what is our boat coming in
well looks good to me so i don't think
you need to worry about a thing uh
seems to match up pretty good um got
about
i'm like two for four on killing people
coming through here so
you are in luck you're improving my
ratio and you get to go on vacation
i think it's a good day for everybody
there's that and
there's that i didn't scan you
probably fine shut this bad boy down
blood um how much money did i make i am
so out of energy i got 12 bucks did i
make money today i feel like i didn't
make money
all right on the way home to my
beautiful wife
and family and mother-in-law maybe i
could grab an energy drink on the way
back or something
i really shouldn't have spent my money
on that party but it was a
bitchin party remembering that ladies
undulating
facial structure i guess she had boobs
too so that was cool i'm guessing that
this isn't why they should pick their
border agents by lottery because it just
so happens that
like half of the people going through
are gonna get shot which seems excessive
am i still allowed to go on this party
or do i have to pay again cause i got
just enough money to go again again
i got an axe hell yeah hey
guess who's back it's me
[Music]
i don't think any of the other ones
they're doing this great insane face
thing
your beer beer
and i'm sober okay i'm out of here i've
sobered up real good i'm i'm good
man i'm good now back to my beautiful
wife and
smart son and loving mother-in-law and
bedless uncle do i need to buy him a new
bed is it
is that a thing that i need to do let's
see about getting more energy watch out
i've killed people for way less oh
hand brakes are for nerds hey do you
have an energy drink of some kind
i need an energy drink did i drink it is
it in my inventory
cool glug how do i
do i do i drink it
how do i drink
i did it i gotta make sure i make sweet
tender love to my wife and chocolate for
my son
but sweet tender love for my wife
okay i'm full of energy vim vigor all
that stuff
i am less than half full gas there is no
way in hell i'm driving there number one
it
seems to take forever number two i gas
is probably very expensive and i barely
have enough for chocolate
and crazy dance raves and those are
essentials hey look a shortcut
a shorty cut
geez honey i'm nearly
home for that sweet loving
oh god no i'm fine
i might as well park it here because i'm
never going to drive it again so like
screw that
get out of my life honey
hi mom his bed's gone geez it is
hey kid kid you want some chocolate you
want you want chocolate
there you go sunny wife let's meet in
the night
already agree okay do we just do i just
do
i you want to just can't really shut the
door so
mother-in-law is going to be peering
around the corner there uh
all right let's get to sleepy slough i
guess oh
wife
jesus christ holy crap oh my god
what
oh my god i'm depressed and i'm dead
what i get jump scared by my own wife
and then
that happens what in the fresh hell was
that
okay so this is off to a bad start but
now that i've learned
i think i can do this better now but god
damn it i'm gonna have to drive aren't i
[ __ ] does that mean i can't do raves i
don't know if i want to go through this
again but
i will for the sake of my family to not
die of starvation because i went to one
too many raves wife
yeah you can have a cigarette there you
go that's me in the night
why are you less happy could you
remember
remember how we all starved here fix fix
fix the situation with my son no with my
wife did i just
have i just given away all i've just
given away all my money i'm we're gonna
die
i have to go back here we go okay
all right i swear to god i'm not a
failure family i'm not a failure
i don't need to open the door i know i
know i know a wife
wife you are so sad i don't know why
bam you get happiness and let's meet in
the night
she she denies me all right whatever
it's fine
a border open i'll be back family i'll
be back hey
what's up okay yeah uh-huh we we're good
let's go
my family hates me i just lucked out
last time apparently or they remember
just what exactly i did
all right let's go for it we're going to
take all the shorty cuts because we
don't have time to waste a round
okay i'm going to speed through these
people if you don't pay your rent you're
done yeah
i missed that whole part of
it nailed it hopefully it doesn't seem
like there's car damage so that's good
all right we're doing it we're doing it
we're doing it we're doing it get out of
the way get out of the way all the way
all the way out of the way
oh my god oh my god
i am kind of dumb guys i'm starting to
realize that um
i'm a little uh dumb i don't take things
seriously on the first go and then i
just make more work for myself because
i'm dumb
but here we go back to the border back
to make everything
good for the people of stor vorska oh
there's the bus
okay when does the bus come do i have
any
cool my god do i have any clock
at all is there any clock
bob [ __ ] also buy a car apparently bye
whatever it don't matter okay i'm gonna
nail this one n i know exactly what to
do
next for your documents give me the scan
oh you see four lady where's the bomb
get my gun my freaking gun oh oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] arrest
put on my military i'm worried about
this because i feel like she would just
blow it up
right she would just blow up
nicely done next don't worry about that
fine don't worry about it it's all good
hey
buddy how are you did i shoot you last
time
i hope i didn't you are such a nice
owahamaho indeed all right everything's
looking in order here uh
dude what did he i wasn't paying
attention i gotta look at the dialogue
again
what did you say your birth student okay
cool you're good to go
buddy you're good to go give me approval
on this bad boy and
for bomb and my uncle's bed has been
stolen for some reason
all right here we go
can i i would love to grab this what
there
what
[Applause]
i'll shoot you get out of here
there's that and shut up shut up
next my wife will be here tomorrow
don't let them through cryeva
crieva creava okay so crieva i don't let
her through
okay this is all looking great i like
this
and you know what i i hear you about the
wife am i right
yeah oh yeah you got it buddy
thanks for the tip next i'm flying
through these i'm gonna make so much
money today
it's based on person right
get out of here get out of here
let me make sure you don't need to be
arrested first you freak
oh what is this what is this a spoon no
spoons
get out of here hate you too buddy hate
you too
well look at this fun gentlemen look at
this look at this fine gentlemen
look at this half-life 2 model gentlemen
diplomat
okay so they just need the diplomat
permit
shalom yep yoleshi name
number all good to me you're good to go
buddy you're good to go
hey congratulations on being a diplomat
whatever that means and does
next get here now hi
[Music]
don't try to fake me out with that kind
of stuff it would never work
did what did you say your visit before
was was a visit transfer
no no no
you said transfer how
freaking dare you don't lie to me
don't mind me my ears cheek man hey
chick man
hey chick chick with your pants
documents out of these controls yeah me
too buddy me too buddy
business huh it's not this you
shut your face and get out of my place
wish i had rejected your mom you will
never never born look
look man i shot you last time i could do
it again it cost me five bucks
hey this is the guy's pictures on your
passport hello
oh what do we got
oh [ __ ] oh god the rest is man
simple farmer with a butcher knife time
to go all right
good day's work hey this is job well
done
what a day time to get back to my wife
get some cigarettes for her get some
chocolate for the sun maybe a beer i'm
full of money look at my money
i feel like i wasn't paid per person 33
bucks doesn't seem like a lot of money i
had 15 going into that i feel like i
should have made more than 18
i mean i did get docked pay once but
thought i would have made more baby
oh you indestructible deer [ __ ] you get
out of here before i ruin your entire
existence
okay hey what's up man give me an energy
drink please
energy discount rate because i'm happy
is that
is that true chocolate for the boy
cigarettes for the wife
where's the cigarettes oh you don't have
cigarettes there we go uh
sir are you okay and on the way home
won't be much longer now
family who i love very dearly and i do
this for and i struggle
every day because it's worth it and at
the end of the day
i get to see the happiness of my family
and that is what gets me through the day
that's all that really matters in the
end the happiness of
my family and seeing their smiling faces
every time i come home honey i'm home
please
honey please there's hell out there
i literally don't have enough gas to go
there and back again
give me the drink give me the juice so i
can
make sweet tender love to my wife wife
cigarette let's meet in the night oh
we'll be energetic all right
son chocolate you work on that
voice of yours i'm not gonna pay until
we know we can afford it
sleep get ready for i had to be more
it's not worth it no sorry not worth it
all right i've been broken by this game
it's too much it's too real it's too
close to real
it's too close to home it's too it's
too good for me
the weak willed person that i am is too
much
going through that drudgery every day
and not even getting the sweet
tender loving of my wife but oddly
enough this game was surprisingly decent
it definitely is more than papers please
because it's the whole thing
i'm pretty sure this is not going to be
a situation like a live stream live
streaming simulator where
i'm going to keep playing it in the
background i think a one and done is
good for me i'm
i'm set thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to check this out
link in the description
but just warning you it's real
fun thank you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
go